François Legault
semble
à court d'arguments, alors
qu'il se creuse la tête
pour répondre à une question
sur l'immigration.
premier ministre du Québec
- Bien, ce qu'on sait
actuelleactuellement, c'est qu'a
un déclin du nombre de Québécois
qui parlent français. Donc...
- Mais comment vou
- Bien, on regarde d'abord
la situation actuelle.
- Le premier ministre n'est pas
en mesure de dire pourquoi
la capacité d'accueil du Québec
est de 5e. C'est pourtant
le discours qu'il répète depuis
des semaines, à l'instar de son
ministre responsable du dossier.
JEAN BOULET, min.,
Francisation et Intégration, Qc
- Et le seuil pour cette année,
c'est 50 000, puis
ce seuil-là. Et c'est
ce que M. Legault dit.
- Radio-Canada a demandé
de dévoiler les études
qu'il possède à ce sujet.
Deux documents nous ont été
envoyés, mais ni l'un ni l'autre
n'affirme que la capacité
d'accueid'accueid'accueil du Qut
de 50 000 immigrants.
- C'est un gouvernements les ex.
- La cheffe du Parti libéralacce
fi du manque de main-d'oeuvre
au Québec et surtos qui
s'apprêtent à devenir
des résidents permanents.
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe,
Parti libéral du Q2 au Québec, ,
c'est 70 000. Ça veut donc dire
qu'on est capable collectivement
d'accueillir 70 000 personnes
cette an- C'est sans compter
les dizaines de milliers
d'autres qui arrivent
avec un statut temporaire.accuet
vraiment immigrants,
le gouvernement doit pouvoirn d.
- Est-ce
c'est problématique?urrait le u!
ex-directrice
au ministère de l'Immigration
sera nécessaire pour trouver
un consensus.
ANNE-MICHÈLE MEGGS, ex-dir.
ministère de l'Immigration
- Est-ce qu'on a regardé les liens entre le nombre
de personnes qui arrivent de l'étranger,
peu importe leur statut,
et le taux d'occupation
des logements, par exemple,
ou les espaces en CPE ou dans les écoles?
Ce genre de choses-là, on n'a
pas regardé, dans le passé.
- Une consultation
lieu cette année au Québec
pour discuter des seuils
d'immigr
Mais le gouvernement l'a
repoussée
en raison des élections
prévues cet automne.
Ici Alexandre Duval,
Radio-Canada, Québec